you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
boris johnson insists that cop 26 can be
the beginning of the end of climate
change but it seems even conservative
voters don't trust him on the issue
ending climate change will mean 1.5
needs to stay alive we'll look at the
six actions published today aimed at
keeping global warming below one and a
half degrees
and lab grown meat could apparently add
2 billion pounds to the uk economy so
should it be given the go-ahead
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
there's now a month to go until the cop
26 climate summit gets underway in
glasgow and today it's president alex
sharma revealed that more than 100 world
leaders have confirmed that they will
attend in person although china which
will still send a delegation is not one
of them well despite that apparent
setback boris johnson who today
addressed the youth cop event in milan
by video link insisted that the summit
could be the beginning of the end of
climate change so long as those world
leaders address the four issues that are
fast becoming a mantra for him
there are four things that we want to
come out of
of cop 26 for for big changes in our
approach and and it's very easy to
remember it's coal cars cash and trees
coal cars cash and trees we want we want
to move away as i've described want to
move away from using coal as uh the way
we generate uh electricity we want to
move towards renewable all the countries
in the world to to move off coal
but there's bad news for mr johnson on
the environment front this evening
courtesy of a new poll shared
exclusively with sky news our climate
change correspondent hannah thomas peter
is in milan with the details so hannah
what have you learned then
well the pollen's been done by the
conservative environment network so you
you'd expect them to ask questions that
might be favorable for the prime
minister but actually the polling has
revealed
that just 25
of adults polled think that a
conservative government led by boris
johnson is the best choice to handle
climate change and environment issues
but 32 percent of those same adults
thought that kia stammer would be a
better option and actually only 50
percent of the conservative party's own
voters thought that boris johnson would
be the best choice on environment issues
and a significant proportion of those
surveyed thought that the government is
undercooking its response
to climate change now
those headlines will not be comfortable
reading for boris johnson but there is
some good news hidden in there which is
that the government's net zero approach
to get to net zero carbon emissions by
2050 enjoys very broad cross-party
support and actually voters want the
government to do more and think that it
should be a top priority when it comes
to spending that will give boris johnson
a mandate when he reads this poll uh to
to go further to spend more and he's
certainly going to have to do that the
government has not yet published its net
zero strategy or its homes and building
strategy which is how to decarbonize the
heating in millions of british homes
that's a domestic context but as you say
a huge amount of international diplomacy
going on now a big last push
into the cop 26 meeting in glasgow and
lots of problems left to resolve will
there be enough cash on the table for
developing nations will there be more
enhanced commitments to reducing carbon
emissions and will there be an agreement
before cop 26 from big coal consumers
and producers to finally phase out coal
for good
hannah thanks very much indeed
well if cop26 really is going to be the
beginning of the end of climate change
as boris johnson hopes whatever's
decided in glasgow needs to curtail the
rise in global warming well today the
energy transitions commission published
the six actions that it hopes can keep
1.5 alive describing one of them is
particularly crucial that's cutting
methane emissions by 40
by 2030
and so the first action is significant
and rapid reduction in methane emissions
now the gas mainly released through
agriculture especially cows and the
burning of fossil fuels is estimated to
be responsible for up to 40 percent of
global warming so far
well next is halting deforestation and
beginning reforestation and that could
reduce greenhouse gas emissions by six
and a half gigatons by 2030 and that's
about a fifth of the planet's entire
emissions
the third action is decarbonizing the
power sector now an immediate ban on new
coal-fired power plants and the phase
out of existing plants could reduce
emissions by a further three and a half
gigatons
now accelerating the shift to electric
vehicles could reduce emissions by an
additional 2.3 gigatons while reducing
emissions from buildings industry and
heavy transport would save another
gigaton
and finally there's a call for energy
and resource efficiency to be
reinvigorated an international agreement
to improve the energy efficiency of new
buildings could deliver an additional
1.4 gigaton reduction of co2 by 2030.
well lord turner is the chair of the
energy transitions commission and he
joins me now lord turner is keeping 1.5
alive then doable and affordable
it's undoubtedly technically doable and
many of the actions that we need to take
which you've just described have either
negative costs or very low costs i would
say four out of those six categories
really don't cost the global economy
anything there are things where the
technologies are driving us forward
towards progress and we just have to
seize that opportunity two of them
ending deforestation and phasing out
existing coal as well as ending new coal
that does involve a cost and we've got
to work out who's going to pay for it
and whether the developed world is going
to help the developing world with that
which is why that fourth of what boris
johnson talked about cash is an
important thing as well so i think on
those two we got to have a debate about
who's going to bear some actual cost to
get there on the other four i think we
should be confident that the
technologies will get us there at a
relatively low cost as well as as long
as we force the pace of change well yes
and we have known for some time haven't
we that the actions you've identified
can reduce emissions so how confident
are you that your report will make any
difference it'll make governments and
industry change their habits
well look you're absolutely right that
broadly speaking the actions we need to
take to reduce emissions are
there at one level obvious they are
known already i think one of the things
that we're doing is drawing attention to
methane there hasn't been enough
attention on on methane as well as co2
but in relation to the others what we've
done is clearly work out their relative
importance work out how much difference
one could actually make as early as 2030
and try to identify the specific levers
that could be pulled at cop26
by
leading groups of countries and
companies without having to get
agreement with all 196 countries and
those sort of leading coalition
opportunities are ones which we should
try to seize okay lord turner thanks
very much indeed for your time this
evening
thank you
well let me take you over now to our
climate data dashboard and show you just
how hard a task is going to be to keep
global warming below one and a half
degrees now temperatures have already
increased as you can see here by more
than 1.23 degrees celsius since
pre-industrial levels and the current
estimate is that will hit that crucial
level in just over 11 years
you